katerina s'est engagé au début de la
guerre dans une section de déminage la
vie de caserne c'est tout nouveau pour
celles qui travaillaient dans le design
dans le milieu du luxe
un jour où il ya ici c'est la chambre où
je dors on est 10 à vivre ici là j'ai
deux camarades qui viennent de rentré de
mission je parle tout bas pour ne pas
les réveiller ils dorment
ce qui est important pour moi c'est
protéger ma patrie
le confort rudimentaire c'est pas un
problème
vous savez il ya beaucoup de filles qui
combattent sur la ligne de front et
elles vivent dans les tranchées
katerina a tout appris posé des mines
pour ralentir l'ennemi des mines et les
engins explosifs mais pour l'instant
elle nous raconte comment elle conçoit
le checkpoint pour faire de kiev une
ville imprenable
moi en tant qu ingénieur de formation je
m'occupe des fortifications et je suis
tout le temps en déplacement dans la
ville pour créer différents types de
barrage
des check polt comme celui-ci installés
aux carrefours stratégiques l'objectif
piéger les chars russes pour mieux les
détruire et les empêcher de pénétrer
dans le centre ville dans les immeubles
de bureaux à l'abri des regards une
armée de bénévoles de réservistes et
d'anciennes combattante s'occupe du
soutien des troupes
si vous pouvez la porter s'écoule sinon
on ira le chercher
katia est une ancienne combattante la
guerre elle connaît aujourd'hui son
obsession que les gars et les filles
dans les tranchées reviennent en vie et
elle vient de recevoir une bonne
nouvelle
ça y est les gilets pare balles qu'on a
commandé à l'étranger sont arrivés
un stock attendue depuis près de deux
semaines qui va être rapidement
distribués aux combattants tous n'ont
pas les meilleures protections face à la
puissante armée de vladimir poutine
et ioulia a combattu quatre ans les
forces pro russes dans le donbass
aujourd'hui réservistes elle affiche sur
son bras le symbole national il est
comment l'ennemi russe aujourd'hui
je pense que l'ennemi russe n'a aucun
principe je pense qu'ils n'ont même pas
besoin de notre pays qui sont venus ici
pour tout détruire et ils font tout pour
ça donc en ce qui me concerne je pense
qu'il faut se préparer au pire les
finales
tous les civils savent manier les armes
s'il le faut et de retourneront sur la
ligne de front encadrés par des
militaires après les gilets pare balles
ce sont des sacs de couchage qui arrive
d'angleterre il ya aussi des cocktails
protéines et qui doivent arriver
certains équipements sont achetés il y a
aussi beaucoup de dons et tout ça va se
retrouver très vite sur la ligne de
front